[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning and we
begin with this a major development in
the flint water crisis just moments ago
the state of michigan announced it has
reached an agreement to settle
all claims with victims you may recall
that people in that city the city of
flint have protested for years over
unsafe amounts of lead in their drinking
water
the preliminary agreement calls for a
payment to
city residents of 600 million dollars
and it follows more
than a year and a half of negotiations
adriana diaz has done extensive
reporting on this story
from flint and she joins us now adriana
good morning on the one hand 600 million
dollars might sound like a lot
but on the other there was a lot of
damage there as well how are residents
of flint reacting this morning
good morning although the state claims
that flint's water quality has met
federal standards for three
years now many residents tell us they
don't trust officials
and they still don't trust the water one
person told us yesterday that no amount
of money
can heal the suffering of those impacted
by this crisis
and the coronavirus pandemic is just
making their situation
worse it ain't worth nothing
money money don't equal health like it
don't you can be rich and die
like it ain't it ain't the same craig
davis is a lifelong flint resident who
has
lived the devastation brought on by the
city's tainted water crisis
it's almost like we got ptsd with the
water because who won't really drink it
comfortably like
you know what i'm saying when people
actually lost their lives to it he's
also a coronavirus survivor
and says he and his neighbors are
struggling to deal with both
issues at the same time now you got
people that's taking extra money out
their pockets
and just going to the grocery store and
just buying up the water in the grocery
store
but you add on the pandemic now the
water is not even there
to even grab the water crisis started in
2014 when as a
cutting measure officials switched the
city's water source from lake huron to
the flint river
but the water was improperly treated
allowing
lead and other chemicals from the pipes
to leach into the water supply
the city switched back to its original
water source in 2015.
my heart breaks because the fact of the
matter is i handed them
the glasses of water cbs news was on the
ground in flint for months at the height
of the crisis
we heard firsthand from parents about
how they believed the tainted water
affected their children when i hear my
son get up at night
and cry because his bones hurt and
there's nothing i can give him there's
nothing i can
do for him to take away his pain
i feel completely helpless although tens
of thousands of plaintiffs are
reportedly set to receive a payout as
part of the settlement
much of the money is expected to go
toward the children affected by the
crisis
flint mayor sheldon neely says he hopes
this settlement provides some sense of
victory for families
it allows flint residents to move
forward in a positive way
getting out of the mindset of being
victims but more of as victors
and that's where we need to move as a
community